I made it. I survived a sleepover with like 9,
9 year olds. You can tell by my face,
I am absolutely exhausted.
Some of the girls, including my daughter,
the birthday girl, stayed up until like 2 or 3 in the morning
no matter what I tried to do,
tried to get them to sleep
like every 30 minutes. I could hear them.
They were loud, but it was like,
it's girl head. They wanted to stay up all night
and chat and giggle with their friends.
So like, what are you gonna do?
It's kind of like the point of a slumber party.
So today is a down day. Today is I'm doing Nothing Day.
I'm not even like, really cleaning up from the party.
Everything that needs to be done can be done tomorrow.
It's not gonna be a big deal if we just leave it.
But it was so cute and so magical.
I'm gonna post like,
the party prep and the theme and all that stuff in the decorations,
cause it was. It was so great.
My daughter had such a good time.
This was definitely a core memory birthday.